well welcome everyone first of all thank
you very much for waiting in the hot Sun
outside line to come to our presentation
my name is JP and I'm Peter and we're
here from the Google developer training
team and we're excited to present our
first Google certification associate
Android developer a performance-based
exam real right real apps to show your
skill so the Google developer training
team I'm just yeah meet all of you as
part of the developer relations team at
Google and at the in this team we our
mission really is to educate and inspire
developers and we'd like to do it at
that scale so what we like to do is help
developers like yourself teach the best
practices the design patterns the tips
and tricks that you need to know to
build high quality apps in the most
efficient way possible
now JP and I and other parts of members
of the training team that are also here
today we've been in this training world
for a while and one of the things about
developer certifications is you know
whether you should do it or not and it's
kind of a tricky balance many
certification programs kind of missed
the mark of what they're intending to
try to do and so at the same time we
felt that the certification could really
set the bar for you know helping people
achieve some of their goals career wise
job wise and really accomplish what they
want to do and that's what we're trying
to trying to set up with this program
here today we're really excited about so
what we want to do today is give you a
short view of the program introduce you
to associate Android developer and
really show you how to get started we
want to keep this short and sweet we
want to give you a lots of time for
questions and answers and give you lots
of time so you can get a good seat for
the concert too so imagine a developer
she does this amazing app and she wants
to change the world now if you're
already an entrepreneur or an
independent app developer you can do
this today and we even have training to
help you
however there's other situations
situations where it's not quite so easy
to go from zero to hero we're developers
around the world look for and need
resources to help them accomplish their
dreams so one of these situations which
is familiar to probably many of us is
getting a job maybe you or someone you
know is looking for a job as an app
developer maybe it's a first job or
maybe it's a new job or a new career you
have ideas you have skills you have a
network but maybe you can't quite
connect to employers to land that job
there's really a gap between skilled
developers and those jobs will let them
fulfill their dreams now as as Peter and
Eileen started to look at this gap and
other members of the chaîne team looked
at this gap we just discovered that was
really I'd say the way larger than we
thought we saw it in developer education
we saw in the job market we saw where
skills that employers were looking for
and how people were treating to get
those jobs and really two questions
arose the first question for employers
how do you show that somebody is
qualified how do you know that somebody
can perform the tasks that are required
to them the second one for individuals
how do you stand out for job interviews
and get recognized whether it's for a
new job or promotion now separately a
lot of industry studies came out that
showed that we had a significant
disadvantage here for example this
report from vision mobile really pointed
that down and you know we realized that
we the lack of this objective industry
standard was really holding us back and
specifically in in different countries
around the world now we started thinking
about this quite deeply and we have to
say this kind of something that kept us
up at night we really wanted to solve
that for for Google now generally with
the rise of these alternative
credentialing methods like the ones
you're probably familiar with with
Udacity and General Assembly we realized
that it was a real appetite for
learning app development that would
directly lead to jobs and so over the
last few years we've done quite a bit to
close this gap and perhaps a lot of you
are already familiar with some of our
training but I'll go in a little bit
more detail on that as well
so for example with Udacity our online
training partner we built 35 MOOC
training courses providing end-to-end
paths for android development web
development and tech entrepreneurship we
also built other courses around machine
learning and cloud computing and so on
now over the last few years these the
people enrolling in this have really
dramatically increased and it's still
picking up a lot of steam for example we
now have one and a quarter million
people enrolled in our Google courses on
Udacity and we have about 2,500 people
enrolling in these courses every single
day right now so it's been been a really
good platform for us to get the message
out rent to educate developers which is
our original mission now we also realize
that not everyone learns with the same
you know online and self-paced and so we
work together with General Assembly to
build a complete 12 week Android
immersive the sort of a full time
in-person course where you go on-site
and spent 12 weeks really dedicated to
that whereas most of the online learning
is sort of self-paced and we just had
our first people graduate from that the
first cohort in New York about 25 people
and the next one is graduating very soon
here in San Francisco and there's going
to be opening up about 12 other
locations globally so I want to take
just a quick step back about so what
we've done specifically to Android two
years ago at i/o we release the first
Android fundamentals or developing
Android apps training course with
Udacity and that's that's sort of our
flagship Android course it's the you
know we have almost 300,000 people
enrolled and of course I think it's 288
thousand at last count and this is the
course that's developed by radio Meyer
Katherine Kwan who is here in the
audience and Dan Galpin so a really
great course but at that time we were
still building very in a very ad hoc
manner so we were building one course on
html5 games and another one on mobile
web development and another one on
Android fundamentals but you know we
were still we need we were we're lacking
was that sort of well lit path for
developers through an entire curriculum
that would lead directly to jobs and so
we decided to start building that and
last year at i/o sundar announced that
we launched the android nanodegree and
later in the year we launched that in
September or relaunch that effectively
in India with local pricing a thousand
scholarships and you know local
e-commerce options for Indian students
to take that as well and of course they
could have taken that by itself already
now late last year we started seeing the
first graduates from these nano degrees
it takes generally about six to 12
months for people to complete we hosted
the career summit in Mountain View for
about the 50 top students and what we're
seeing there's like people are getting
jobs for example in India we have 16
nano degree students and keep in mind
that this is still kind of early days
because it takes 6 to 12 months and when
it's only been 12 months and out of
these six students four of them were
hired without even as much as an
interview at Flipkart so pretty pretty
amazing stories some of these graduates
have also been hired at Google so a
pretty high level of mastery and just a
great outcome we also launched last year
the Android for beginners course now
this is a fantastic course all you need
for that is a phone a computer where you
can install Android studio and an
internet connection you can take that
course and really take you from zero
programming experience all the way to
surely having apps running on your
machine as Katherine Kuan and Shanaya
who are here in the audience today
somewhere raise your hand there all
right right thank you so we launched up
as well last year so then fast forward
to next year this year sorry we realized
there was still a big gap generally we
say that for Android fundamentals in the
android nanodegree you need about two
years of programming experience android
for beginners takes you part of the way
there but it's not quite complete and so
we've been working really hard in fact
Katherine and Shannon I've been working
really hard on bridging that gap in
intermediate Android development skills
and so stay tuned for some really
exciting announcements in that space
because we're building out effectively
an entire end-to-end path for developers
on Android so that we no longer have to
tell people you know if you want to go
and learn about we want to take the
android nanodegree go off and go to
these sixteen different places to learn
the prerequisites so we'll have an
end-to-end zero to hero path through all
of that so in summary we've come a long
way to closing that gap that JP
described when we're trying to
accelerate that gap even further and so
today we're taking one step closer to
super charging how employers and
employees can effectively work together
in the most efficient way today we're
excited to announce Google developer
certification a new program to help
close the gap for employers and job
seekers to help set common standards and
to help developers worldwide now we're
very excited about this program we think
it's going to help developers stand out
be recognised get a job help build
higher quality apps and I'm going to
tell you a little about the details what
it contains and how you can benefit now
if you're an individual if you've got a
great idea
if you're looking for a job or maybe you
represent a company or an agency looking
for talent we think we've got something
for you
now I want to talk a little bit about
how this is not your let's say an
ordinary developer certification or
expel a few myths that you might think
about when you think of developer
certification so one of the big things
here is that it's based on job task
analysis and JP will tell you more about
that in a little bit the big difference
with let's say a typical exam is that
this is performance based exam we're
trying to take certification into 2016
do it in a bit of a googly way and
basically you will need to build apps
and show your skills to pass these exams
it's very performance-based so it's not
a you know I don't know a 200 question
trick question multiple-choice exam
it's not really a knowledge test it's
really testing actual app development so
we thought about this and I think as
Peter was alluding to we thought about
the traditional concept of technical
certification for developers now in
other industries there may be
performance-based exams that work well
but specifically when we're looking at
technical certification perhaps app
developers it was it was something that
we really need to think about so we
thought first we need to make a job
focus as Peter alluded to when we say
job focus we mean that every
certification that we develop is
actually mapped to a job that's in the
industry has determined and vetted by a
job task analysis Peter also mentioned
performance based exams so we take an
exam that we will develop let's just
take one in that you'll be asked to
build extend add functionality to an
existing app or correct determine and
correct defects in the code so we feel
that this is similar to the tasks that
developer would do in the real world for
an entry-level developer and as opposed
to a knowledge-based exam it's going to
evaluate the ability to perform tasks
can you do the tasks require the job not
recall facts or concepts probably one of
the things that's probably most
important for this program is how we're
going to be using rubrics now typically
rubrics you just kind of say okay I know
I have to know these things and
okay if I know these things I'll do well
well there is some aspect of that of
course for us and with graded the
rubrics will be transparent published
you'll have them as soon as you sign up
for exam you'll know what you need to do
in order to pass that exam but it also
reduce ambiguity it's gonna be make it
very clear very empirical and objective
how you'll earn the certification so if
you're prepared if you can build an app
you know these rubrics you should be in
good shape to pass and earn one these
certifications we like to say here is
there's no tricks no guile just
measurable performance right uh yeah so
JB's showed you a little bit about their
overall certification program we're
really excited about that and today
we're launching the first in this series
associate Android developer now this
certification maps to what you would
need to know as an entry-level Android
developer now next slide the exams for
this they will open up in July and so
today it's all about getting prepared
now a lot of you in this audience you're
probably Android developers and you may
already be ready to to pass this exam
but if you're not and you need to brush
up on some of the skills we have a great
training page you can find out all about
our certification and training offerings
that we have to help you get ready so
you can find our new certification page
that we just launched earlier today that
has more details on it you can find
there what these rubrics are that we
talked about what the program is all
about and today you can sign up
literally just put your email in so we
can notify you as soon as the exams open
up so the key takeaway here is you know
you can start your journey toward
certification now how do you prepare so
we're coming back to that landscape of
Android training that we we developed
over the last few years really what this
is about is more on the advanced side on
the intermediate to advanced side which
is based on if we zoom into let's say
that advanced Udacity nano degree then
you can take Android fundamentals
which is really the course to to dive
into that map's to the task with Allison
here can we get the next light right
great so Android fundamentals Maps
closest to the job task analysis that we
performed and so by taking that course
you can really get ready to get the exam
now taking that course also means you
have to do all the practical parts of
that right it's not just watching the
video but it's actually really getting
your hands dirty building the projects
that come with that and really mastering
that that material so lots in essence
what I think the best place to start
with to get started today so that's
great thank you Peter
and that's how you go about preparing
for this exam and you can do that again
starting today so what about July let's
fast-forward a little bit when July
comes what you'll do is you'll complete
your signup process you'll be presented
with some projects basically the
projects will represent what you need to
know in order to pass the exam and then
earn the certification when you get
these projects you'll work on them
independently submit them they'll be
graded and date you'll be certified then
you can take your mark show recruiters
show employers show your friends you
know I don't know hand in front your dog
let me see it you know stuff like that
show your mark so you can proudly show
everyone what you've earned not only
that we looked at grading - the thing
that is you know sometimes in
certifications is it becomes just
something earn - just get just get
through we really wanted to be part of
your learning path towards mastery as
well so when we think about grading for
this it's not pass or fail it's really
you get three chances to pass you can
retake the exam and there's a
combination of machine and human grading
so with the human grading Android
experts will give you feedback so again
it's not just about earning the
certification it's also about learning
as you're doing and building these
projects and well that's it that's what
we have to talk about today thank you
for attending the talk we hope you're
excited about Google
certification to find out more go to our
site read about the program and sign up
you can also get in touch with us we're
going to be here throughout i/o and you
can tweet at us thanks again very much